put on your glasses and hold onto your
heads because we have the best thing to
happen to art since Banksy's dismal and
velvet buzzsaw is a scathing portrayal
of the world of high-end art with
everyone in it seemingly forgetting what
the real purpose of art is and paying a
bloody price for it so in this video I
want to explain this film's ending the
monster and some of the cool details you
may have missed along the way the intro
itself is a work of art stop motion
animation hinting at what's to come fire
a hanging man the bloody footsteps the
kids spread around when gretchen dies
the monkeys attacking through the
painting morph smash glasses and the
paint that seeps into Josefina's skin
were then transported to an art exhibit
in Miami and introduced to more
Vanderwall a well-respected art critic
at the top of his game in fact his
reviews can make or break an artist and
he is accosted by several such as
Claudio who wants him to look at hobo
man a representation of what has become
of America notices American vest
mimicking that of the star-spangled
banner a decrepit old man on his last
leg literally he recalls times of
greatness telling morph that he once
built a railroad railroads playing a
pivotal role in the creation of America
and catapulting the nation to greatness
we're also introduced to the sphere a
special piece of art which morph
absolutely adores giving it a positive
review and having its price soar on the
art market ridore ahir explains that it
creates a unique sensation depending on
each person this unique sensation of
putting your hand and something to feel
again is juxtaposed when morph puts his
hand up Josefina's dress and also when
gretchen puts her hand in and has it
brutally dismembered resulting in her
death hey and it's good to see velvet
buzzsaws a prequel to burr box with
another role for John Malkovich at the
art after party morph consoles Josefina
ro Dora's assistant who's just been
dumped by her artist boyfriend Ricky she
tells him I'm dating artists and what
does she do ends up dating an artist and
cheating on morph with an artist the
very thing she accused her ex of doing
John dawn dawn over here love that name
is an art agent trying to
respected artists peers who is currently
suffering from artist's block peers as a
17-year long relationship with rod Oren
is hesitant to jump ship with Don Don
morph seems to be pretty comfortable as
he reviews an exhibit called GoPro
kindergarden in which GoPros are
attached to kindergarteners so we can
see the world from their perspective and
I don't know if it's just me but
watching kindergarteners naked doesn't
seem like the greatest choice
how are you won't you have a seat right
over there Edie morphs lover reads the
review but what we'll find out later is
that he's actually a spy for red aura
since Morse reviews are so influential
if ridore can get the advanced review
she can position herself to either buy
or sell the work depending on whether it
will benefit her think of it as art
insider trading
here at Josefina's apartment she
uncovers a dead man who will later find
out is vet Radice we'll get to him in a
bit but this hiccup makes her late for
work in which ridore scolds her if
Josefina wants to be her Protege she'll
have to step it up and prove it to her
and this is very important in
understanding her character arc we get a
brief glimpse of Raiders tattoo here
which says no death no art 1983 which is
a reference to her friend and
collaborator Pollyanna who died of an
overdose in 1983 they were part of a
punk group called velvet buzzsaw her
artist name hence the tattoo on the back
of her neck she later tells peers when
he's struggling with alcoholism that she
couldn't handle it that's why she gave
up art you sometimes need to step back
and do something for nobody but yourself
so she gives him her private beach house
to get away from it all to sober up and
find himself again which we later find
out he does if you stayed for the end
credits you'll see this scene where
Pierce has finally found himself again
creating art along the beach
back at Josefina's a property manager
tells her that the old man had tons of
art that he requested be destroyed he
also scrapes off his mailbox tag and we
can see his name vet Radice which is an
anagram for three things
devil see art evil art seed and see
lived art so she goes into his apartment
and finds out that he's a masterful
artist this just might be the thing
Josefina needs to gain some traction at
bruh Dora's company in the apartment
you'll notice dese was a hoarder and
recluse he used his pain and focused it
in his paintings studying for masters
like Rembrandt who you can see on the
wall the painting there is a
self-portrait of Rembrandt just like the
painting in the middle here is a
self-portrait of Dees its eyes follow
Josefina around the room kind of like
how many of Rembrandt's paintings do
this in a phenomenon known as linear
perspective it's here we get the first
supernatural element of the movie a
piece of his painting seemingly self
Emma lates whoever made these pictures
never wanted them to be seen Josefina
shows the work to morph who says the
work speaks to him it's amazing and we
get this great transition from morph
seeing the work to an art installation
of a family watching a jackpot
commercial for Josefina she has hit that
jackpot with these paintings ridore
however finds out about the art and
essentially pressures Josefina into
giving it to her in exchange for money
and a partnership within the company so
Josefina gets what she wants but with a
catch the art is now under the control
of her boss and this begins Josefina's
eventual spiral into tragedy she becomes
the very thing she once despised Indra
Dora all about the money and not about
the art this is encapsulated when dam
rush leaves read auras gallery and she
chastises him saying you'd get that off
for what
some sad garage space Pepe graffiti
murals Jesus what's the point of us if
nobody sees us Josefina doesn't
understand what art is about it's not
what others think it's about expression
it's about an artist creating for
themselves and not others damned
Rashad's this
so does piers in the end who regains his
creativity creating on the beach for no
one to see for it to be washed away
later he is creating for himself about a
half hour into the film we also get our
first glimpse of one of the pain
things bleeding as we later find out
from Geetha someone who analyzes
paintings both chemically and
structurally every painting contains
DC's own blood which was used to create
the reds and blacks part of dese is in
every painting both emotionally and
physically private investigator finds
that dese was tortured as a child by his
father so much so that dese burned his
father alive and was sent to a mental
institution one that did tests on its
subjects he was released three decades
later where he spent 42 years as a
janitor lived off the grid and painted
and his pain is seen through his
paintings select the contorted figures
reaching out here the two-faced child
here or the punished child here the
child and father being a representation
of dese and his father
Josephina continues her down world
spiral by convincing morph to do a bad
review to sink her ex's art show and it
works in fact the review makes Ricky the
ex so mad he crashes his car and that
puts them into a coma we're starting to
see a pattern here how all the
characters who do bad things are later
killed by DC's spirit and up next is
Bryson who opens the art he shouldn't
have you'll notice the eyes constantly
watching over him he's been itching to
get a hold of this works and sneaking a
peek at Josefina's desk this backfires
when cigarette ashes light on fire and
he crashes into a gas station
conveniently called humble this is a
great name for a station since almost
none of the characters in this film are
humble they're the exact opposite Bryson
is paying the price and literally
crashing into being humbled and here we
see the first instance of deesis spirit
being able to not only control his own
art but others this monkey picture comes
alive and brutally mauls Bryson to death
just like Howrah Dora told Amrish that
the desire for art charges malls and
devours when morph tells her Dora that
DC's spirit has imbued itself in his art
Road aura brushes it off saying his
dangerous and dangerous indeed dawned on
is the next to die when on the eve of
exposing Dees and his murderous past is
killed by his own art installation and
hung to death it's poor Koko who finds
him dead and also Gretchen and also
morph
Dease the quote-unquote monster spirit
in this movie doesn't just willy-nilly
kill anyone
you'll notice the characters in this
film who die are the ones who don't
respect art Josefina Roy Dora and don
don are all in it for the money
in fact Don Don doesn't know jack about
art he walks into Pierce's studio and
thinks the trash is an installation
morph uses his reviews to make or break
career like how his review of Robo man
killed Claudio sail or his purposely
negative review of Ricky's art show
literally drove the man into a coma he
is killed by the very thing he helped
destroy in his review hobo man who in a
brilliant moment of symbolism crushes
his designer glasses after he chastised
the optometrist for the cheap ones he
had to wear for a few hours after his
exam Gretchen is another interesting
case she starts off on the right side
she works for a museum where art can be
viewed by normal people and not just the
super-wealthy
listen to what she says here look I came
to the museum because I wanted to change
the world through art but the wealthy
vacuumed up everything except crumbs but
Gretchen ends up turning her back on
those values becoming the art advisor to
a wealthy man a man who purchased the
sphere and numerous DS paintings
she even strong-arms her former
employees into giving in to her clients
demands but the strong arm won't last
long as it's brutally ripped apart in
the sphere after DC's spirit takes
control Josefina who has the biggest
change in the film becomes a part of the
graffiti wall after her confrontation
with damn rish for her art is only
high-end or not art at all Andrew Dora
who thinks she may have outwitted the
spirit after getting rid of every piece
of art in her home fails to realize that
the tattoo of velvet buzzsaw on her neck
is in fact a form of art and we all know
how that turns out but look at the
characters who respected art we have
peers who was able to reconnect with his
creativity damn rich who ends up going
back to his roots rather than making art
for the elite and then there's poor Coco
she ends up having to move back to
Michigan with her mom but gets a sweet
cat out of it the same cat that used to
belong to dese so the question we have
to ask ourselves is is the spirit of
Dee's trapped in this cat when ridore is
killed by her velvet buzzsaw the scene
immediately cuts to the
who lets out a terrifying scream
something is definitely causing these
attacks but where it manifests we may
never know Velvet buzzsaw has a great
ironic ending in that the paintings that
once sold for millions are now being
sold on the side of the road by hobos
for $5.00
when ridore and Josefina went to the
detective he stated that the only place
near where Bryson died was an old hobo
camp so this is likely where all that
art went and it's fitting to see that
dese didn't kill the hobos or Coco or
piers because he only goes after the
ones who are abusive the ones jest like
his father
in the end velvet buzzsaws a chilling
expose on how we treat art is it
something to be hoarded and kept to
ourselves or shared and spread equally
what are the consequences of both of
these paths and are we willing to live
with those consequences I hope you
enjoyed this video what did you think of
velvet buzzsaw I want to hear your
comments below make sure to LIKE and
subscribe with that Belon because have
more videos on the way and as always
remember daddy loves you very much